and so after a period of years we came
to this neither of our sons is innately
transgender
I want to say this clearly at that when
we came to that decision I still didn't
see it as a belief system I was still in
it
I was still in it but I had calm
painstakingly both of us add to the
conclusion that um
that our sons weren't actually trans
that it was something else for both of
them and we were clear in that
this belief system the heart of it
says that children should lead and it's
contradictory because once children say
they are the opposite sex then adults
lead them
to gender affirmation okay to cross that
concretizing that cross sex identity and
medicalizing it but what I realized in
those two plus years of Anguish was that
I had led my child into it
and therefore I must lead him out of it
it is my responsibility and like a
second later I'm on my phone I'm texting
a friend I'm like we've realized that
our older son is not actually
transgender and we're going to be
rolling back the social transition and I
feel like I am leaving a cult because
that's what it felt like to me
he said to me
Mama this is your fault
you changed my name
so imagine had we not
you know had we not realized our mistake
and you go 10 20 years into the future
imagine that Mama this was your fault
then
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People well I don't know how to convey
to you how fascinating the guest we have
for you today she's a mother which will
become relevant very quickly Rose
welcome to trigonometry thank you so
much for having me now I'll explain for
our audience that we've had to anonymize
your face and voice because of the
nature of the conversation we're going
to be having before we get into all of
that just tell everybody a little bit
about who are you what is your
background you don't have to give
specifics obviously but just a big
picture of what has been your journey
through life that leads you to be
talking to us
yeah so like you said my name is Rose I
live in the United States and um I would
say the big picture of my life is that
um you know I like everybody else is
just trying to figure out how to live a
good life and uh and my own path that
kind of really led me into being very
involved with social justice as a young
person and then coming into motherhood
and
um and how those beliefs and those views
kind of shaped some of the approaches
that I took to raising my sons and
um that's what I wrote my piece about in
the context of this phenomenon that we
call gender ideology and that's what I'm
here to talk about today yeah well you
wrote a piece on sub stack uh which
we'll put in the in the link for people
to read I remember reading it last year
and
it had a very profound impact on me I
must say because this is kind of where
ideology meets reality in the words of
our recent guest Helen Joyce who also
quote and you are this Progressive
person uh Who's involved in the movement
who's very active uh you get together
with your partner you have a child then
you have another child
and then what happens
well um you know maybe backing up just a
little bit
uh you know I'm a progressive person and
um you know what happens when I have a
child is that I I'm coming into it with
a belief system right
um and and that belief system is
something that that your guess and and
that I would refer to as gender ideology
where this belief system came from I
think when I think back to it is really
as a young person you know being very uh
idealistic uh being involved with a lot
of uh social justice activism but also
we're just struggling to understand like
how the world works and how I can make a
positive impact in it and um along comes
in my early 20s uh uh I answer a really
simple you know Francis I watched your
Joe Rogan interview you know you talk
about be cautious of Simple Solutions to
complex problems
well wow does that resonate with me
because
um I was offered a very simple thing and
that was a formula for understanding uh
the root of our problems and social ills
that could really be boiled down to
these systems of white supremacy of
capitalism of patriarchy that's what I
was given you know just a couple decades
ago there were other ones that were
added since but that's where it was then
um and that a simple formula for for
understanding them and analyzing our
world could be broken down to these
categories of oppressed and oppressor
um and what needed to happen to make the
world a better place was to really
uproot all of this so we could like you
all have spoken to you know create
somewhat of a Utopia I didn't call it
then a few years ago I didn't use that
word but you know now I can see it as
that was really what what I was striving
to be a part of and um
uh I'm going to come back to this later
in the story but I think that was really
the formula and the belief system that
for me led me to believe as a mother and
as a parent that my child or my children
could have
um an innate transgender identity so
when you have that formula of you know
people of color white people men women
you know as the years went by and I was
very involved in the social justice
movement you know
um transgender cisgender you know it's
slotted right into that formula and so I
don't um I know after I wrote the piece
a lot of people like where did this come
from you know where does this come from
and and that I think played a
significant role in where it came from
for me that I didn't do a lot of
questioning of it it just kind of
slotted right in to that bigger ideology
and
um and so my partner and I from the best
intentions imaginable
thought you know if we're having
children we want to acknowledge and we
want to be very proactive that they
could possibly be born male but have
this gender identity that was different
that was a girl and no matter what we
wanted to make sure that our parenting
was
um gonna support that so I think this is
a key point that I want to speak to
throughout the interview is that when
you are in this belief system you truly
believe in this existence of an innate
transgender identity you believe in that
and or many of us do and so
um that's going to make the difference
in these debates and these conversations
around what you do with children who
have gender dysphoria
um so for us it was almost like if we
can be gender neutral if we can um be
more open and flexible
um we could maybe avoid a transgender
child ever having gender dysphoria I
don't know if that makes sense or not it
might sound kind of crazy but but that's
kind of where we were coming from or and
I was coming from was really wanting to
not do harm to my child is kind of the
opposite of what many of us now see as
something that does do harm
so the thing that I've always found very
interesting about your story Rose I mean
the story is fascinating as a whole but
you say that
20 years ago you were you got into this
ideology
20 years ago because to me this is
something fairly new I first came across
these ways of thinking in 2016. so how
did you encounter it 20 years ago
I was just speaking to what I did
already you know I was in college you
know I was idealistic I was an activist
and it was really
um it was within that world that what
you all would call woke ideology was
starting to take root so
anti-globalization protests Iraq war
protests all of those things this
um this whole it was really through
anti-racism and that framework coming in
what what some people refer to as
neo-marxism right now right that sort of
really came in and took hold of
progressive movements and organizations
activism and of course now we see that
you know across all of our institutions
but I I was kind of I would say at the
fledgling
um some fledgling beginnings of that and
Rose what was it about this way of
looking at the world that particularly
appealed to you and you found so
compelling
you know similar to what I already said
it it made things quite simple
um and it also gave a solution which was
you know you see Injustice you know a
war is happening why is that war
happening how can we make it stop
um you know I had been involved once
with some very large protests and
mobilizations and as a young person
you're like we are going to change the
world right but the next day you wake up
and like nothing has changed
so there's a sense of Despair and
confusion and you're looking for an
answer
and so um so I think that this gave me
that answer and kind of gave me a
meaning and purpose for my life
um and when did the gender ideology part
come into it because that to me is
something very very very new
so
um so I would say once I got into that
um the the anti-racism world and you
know as kind of like what I talk about
when I think about it in me it's like
almost like I was evangelized I became
an evangelist right and so a lot of my
work was working with Progressive
organizations to bring this framework in
and help Orient them towards it and so
in that work you know I started to meet
people it would meet people who either
knew transgender people and or who um
you know we were building in that inner
intersectional lens so we had to address
the gender binary we had to you know
introduce people to the concept of
pronouns and this was really within that
greater framework of we're going to
bring this Collective sense of justice
right to the world and all the that
formula all of these identities need to
be part of creating more Justice and so
um so it was introduced to me through
that for sure
um but also as a person person who was
coming out you know as same-sex
attracted as a lesbian My First
Girlfriend
um was younger than me and uh and she
when I said you know I'm interested in
dating women she said I'm well I'm not a
woman
so when you're like Falling in Love
um and you want you're gonna get on
board
um and you're gonna do what you need to
do to support that person's
um expression of who they are and so for
me the gender ideology it came out of
social justice but it also was really
coming up within let's say the female
what would be called now the queer
Community but you know
um within um within those networks as
well just socially and and on the dating
scene
and so coming back to the story of your
family Rose the
I mean the short and the short version
The Cliff Notes version is you had uh
two kids two boys uh and the first one
was quite gender non-conforming you
might say he he's probably on the
autistic Spectrum a bit different and
you raised him in this agenda neutral
way because you believe this is in his
best interest and everything was going
fine and at some point he says he's a
girl and you know you have some
reservations but everyone around you is
delighted for you of how brilliant you
are your these brilliant Progressive
parents uh everyone's supporting you
with this and then your second boy who
is not gender non-conforming in any way
who's just a normal boy
he says he is a girl and at this point
the light bulb book goes off right tell
tell us the story yeah so um
couple things here so things were going
well
um but we were never 100 like this was
the right thing to do and I think you
try to be succinct writing a piece I try
to be succinct in this interview but I
want people to know at no juncture were
we not questioning was this right or not
um part of what the ideology did for me
that I came out of was when you have
questions and doubts you tell yourself
that that's transphobia okay so there's
this self-reinforcing kind of circle
Loop of keeping you in something even
and maybe especially when you're
uncomfortable with it and so um that was
a piece of it for me throughout but um
you know what we had seen in our older
son was difference right we didn't know
we and we still have not I just want to
be very clear because I did get us some
comments on this from the written piece
we see autistic traits in him we've not
pursued a diagnosis but what we saw was
difference and the lens that we saw that
difference through was informed by
gender ideology it was informed by could
my child be trans and so when some of
those differences we couldn't put our
finger on them but at the same time he
was kind of more had this Affinity to
females and female things so because of
the lens we saw that difference through
that's what led us to question whether
he was trans so yes we went with the
program when he finally said you know
I'm a girl yes you can be a girl but we
were never totally comfortable with it
so so you're right something started to
happen
um well I just want to say my partner
would come to me and say things like
what the [__] is gender like literally
um because she had you know she's a
masculine female and she had experienced
you know different desires to be a boy
in her childhood but she never
transitioned was very grateful for that
so she started bringing this to me like
what are we talking about we're talking
what does it really mean
um and then I was at the same time
really learning more about
um attachment and childhood development
and that was starting to give me some of
the answers as to why my older son was a
little bit different and I it was also
starting to raise questions of
is this actually potentially doing some
something harmful to him because I could
see some of these things more clearly
this identification and so
that's when our younger son you know at
three years of age starts saying
I'm a girl and you know when you're when
you're an affirming parent because
that's what I would say we were in
that's why some of our this story is so
unique is that we were what you would
call
affirming parents what parents are being
told to do in this gender affirming
approach you know
um we had started to go to these support
groups
um
for uh you know parents of transgender
children and you know we were in other
kind of networks where our kids were
being asked their pronouns and so our
younger son starts to say she her and
we're just like hold on a second no
um so a few different things happened
um you know at that juncture first and
foremost it caused us to question
everything so those questions that we
had already had we started to listen to
them much more we started to allow them
and um for my partner you know I was
still like but no we know our older son
is because of all of these things and
she was like no you know we know our
younger son isn't our older son is
likely not either but we we took this to
the group we took this to the group we
took it to the gender therapist and I
think that's one of the most shocking
parts of the story when I look back
is the fact that we walked into that
therapy appointment
said our you know our our four I think I
can't refuse three or four by the time
we went to the therapist
um and you know we said we started
saying he's a girl too but we think it's
because he wants to be close to his
older sibling and
um and she said well
she you know immediately she switched to
saying she for our younger son just
within SEC literally seconds you know
you hear these stories of my child
wasn't assessed
assessment doesn't exist when you
believe that someone is innately trans
assessment is actually in violation of
that
so when you're through assessment is
transphobia correct
um
so because you're doubting that person
and you're saying there's something
wrong with that
innate identity right that innate uh
self and so so bam she her you need to
change you know you need to change her
pronouns at home and uh miraculously
enough when we we doubted this we
questioned it we're like okay we'll give
it a try
um when I did that and I tried to
connect with my younger son that night
oh you know you're my girl
um I love you so much he said no mama
don't call me that
and so it was just one of those
um things that another thing where I was
like this isn't right you know
something's not right here and so we did
a very deep dive you know in um deeper
into these questions of attachment and
where we actually saw those differences
then from my my older son as as both
being
um you know what might have given him
that Affinity so when you talk about
kids who are on the Spectrum for example
um you know they uh have difficulties
with personal attachment and so whereas
my younger son wanted to be the same as
his older brother by saying he was a
girl what we came to see from my older
son in part was that he had that same
drive for sameness but it was towards
things because it was too vulnerable for
him to attach to people and so that
feminine you know I like the barrettes
or I like the flowers you know that we
saw through that lens of he could that
could mean he's trans
um was that a function of that
psychologically and um
and we also saw that those special
interests changed over time so we
started to see like this is actually not
about this gender Essence it's really
about him
um and a deeper emotional process and so
after a period of years we came to this
neither of our sons is innately
transgender I want to say this clearly
at that when we came to that decision I
still didn't see it as a belief system I
was still in it
I was still in it but I had come
painstakingly both of us add to the
conclusion that um
that our sons weren't actually trans
that it was something else for both of
them and we were clear in that
one last thing of this is really
important that I want to say is that
this belief system the heart of it
says that children should lead
I just want people to hear this
this is so critical
and it's contradictory because once
children say they are the opposite sex
then adults lead them
to gender affirmation okay to cross that
concretizing that cross-sex identity and
medicalizing it okay but the if you're
gonna call it a religion if you're going
to call it a belief system whatever you
call it
the sacred core
is children must lead
but what I realized in those two plus
years of Anguish was that I had led my
child into it
and therefore I must lead him out of it
it is my responsibility
I am the one who's taking him off I saw
it as a highway where Drive I drove him
on the on-ramp I'm driving him off
and what you have to understand is that
in that process for us to actually say
that to some people who are in this
belief system that is so deeply wrong
it is absolutely counter to the core of
of what um what people are relying on uh
that your children is the one who must
lead you
um even though they're then going to be
led
so we did that we came to the decision
that um
that this was in his best interest that
this was in his best interest
um and so just to tell that story a
little bit
um you know
we were trying to figure out like
how do we um
how do we get them out because this is
not rational it's emotional how do we
get them out and so one of his special
interests at that time was chickens he
loved chickens and um this is funny in
the sense that we go back to the Matt
Walsh film you know that scene uh so
chickens played a role here too but um
but you know what we decided to say to
him in a way he could understand
emotionally was um you're a rooster
you know honey you're a rooster and so I
came up with some bullet points you know
for this conversation I sat him down and
um I said you know I you know I'm so
sorry that I told you something
different uh now I know more I was wrong
and you are a rooster
I know that means that males cannot be
female
it also means that a male can't be a
girl because he always knew he was male
but we had this I like like kids are
going to understand the difference
between gender and sex but anyways you
you cannot be female that means you
cannot be a girl
and
um I know you it feels like you can't
live without it because once it was in
it was locked real tight okay and this
is part of that psychology that we don't
get to when the ideology is keeping us
on the surface we don't get to that
deeper piece
I know that you can't live you feel like
you can't live without it but you can
and you're actually going to be much
happier because I did truly at that
point I saw the ways that it was
impacting him psychologically that we're
not in his best interest and so
um you know he was mad
I knew he would be mad and
um he said to me
Mama this is your fault
you changed my name
so imagine had we not
you know had we not realized our mistake
and you go 10 20 years into the future
imagine that Mama this was your fault
then
so I said yeah you're right you're right
and this is another part of the story
that just you know I want to share
um
I knew he was going to be mad I knew
what I was trying to get to the sad I
was trying to get to the sad
because that was going to tell me that
he had understood what what Dr Gordon
newfeld who I just want to plug here the
book his book hold on to your kids this
concept of futility which is an
essential part of us adapting to life
maturing in life it's when we come
against something we cannot change
and our our heart is soft enough to feel
that vulnerability and cry about it and
so I knew my son had to some point get
to those tears
where he was accepting something that he
couldn't change
and
um so but the Mad came first and we I
decided we're gonna go on a bike ride
you know we're gonna go I'm going to let
him lead I'm gonna put him in the front
because I knew these Dynamics were at
play and
um as we're walking out the door getting
on the bikes he turns around to me and
he had this a lot with a lot of these
highly sensitive kids and autistic you
know Spectrum kids it's like there's
this mature you know they're less mature
in some way so he lives in this
imaginary world he you know had this
farm he was gonna create in his future
called Wildwood farm and um he turns to
me and he just gives me these dagger
eyes and he says mama
you are not invited to Wildwood Farm
and it just hit me again this incredible
validation
for this decision that we were making to
lead him off that Highway this is a
child
this is a child he is uninviting me from
an imaginary Farm
he has no ability to understand
the consequences of changing his sex
um
so in the days after that you know he
did get to those tears
he did get to those tears and what I
write about in the piece and what I want
to share with you is that I imagined
that he would be mad at me for a very
long time and I was expecting it was
going to be hard I was not expecting
that the very next day what I would
experience in my son was a great sense
of relief
a great sense of rest and literally when
we talk about being in the lead and how
this put him into the lead
that's deeply unsettling for a child
they might they might express it through
being bossy or being you know in all
these ways we might interpret as
willfulness or confidence or tightly
holding on to something but ultimately
they need to rest knowing that we've got
them
you know that we're taking care of them
and so when I when I took that back
he was able to set this adult burden
down and he literally spent the next 24
hours leaning into me
um and and even his whole you know just
you could just feel palpably
um that he was laying the burden down
um
yeah the thing the thing that I've
noticed rose with you know when people
talk about this and obviously you know I
was a teacher and I I was very lucky in
my teaching career I taught everything
from the age of four kindergarten right
the way through to 18.
and you listen to people's stories and
if you were told our grandparents
generation or our mother's generation
what we were doing they would be saying
well but that's against everything that
we know to be true that is against every
type of instinct a mother has how have
we reached this point where we're so
willing to subvert our instincts for a
for an ideology
it's such a good question
um it's such a good question I wish I
had the answer I wish I had the answer
but I I do think that that
it's a subversion of instincts but it's
also an inversion of reality like I I
keep on coming back to that because
parents who are in this are um
absolutely believing they're doing the
right thing for their child so all of
those instincts
to protect at all costs are there but
it's based on something that is not real
[Music]
no that's I I mean and so I I don't know
how to answer that question because I
think that is the power of having this
locked in belief system
yeah it's a power of ideology and and
this is I mean one of the things I
wanted to say is the internet is a mean
place and people will you know have
their own
views about your story and and what your
family went through but I I think it's
really important that you you wrote the
piece that you wrote and that you're
here speaking with us now because I
think it's important uh that as you say
people recognize that
um you know it's easy to think or you
know a bunch of stupid evil people over
there are doing the same whereas
actually you know you're clearly very
intelligent
um you're clearly extremely well
intentioned for your kids but this is
why Francis and I have spent so much
time talking about this issue because
ideology is incredibly powerful and if
you find people who are looking for
meaning and purpose and want to feel
good about themselves and want to quote
and quote change the world then you give
them a system of beliefs that preys on
those desires and offers them these
oversimplified Solutions you can get a
lot of harm done without anybody ever
wanting to do anything bad yeah yeah and
so let me um yeah let me speak to that a
little bit and maybe I don't know if
this will get to your question Francis
or not but um
but
I'm gonna go back again putting the
child in the lead so this core of this
ideology so I want to explain how that
then plays out for parents okay
um when you put your child in the lead I
you know you say you're you I know
you're born a male but you say you're a
girl then you're a girl you know or
asking a lot of parents in this in this
belief system young parents you know
Progressive like they're asking their
kids what their gender is right so
they're kind of subverting that natural
hierarchical relationship and putting
kids here right leading this
um so you have that going on but then
when and that's really impacts the
entire relationship and as well as the
kids emotional stability
um
then you have
um an ideology that says if your child
then expresses that they're the opposite
sex
they are transgender
and that that's now safe that's a sacred
category I'm gonna use those words that
is a sacred category
and it's one when you plug it into the
formula oppressor oppressed oppressed
privileged if you're a cisgender or you
don't identify as trans you can't know
your child I mean that's what this
belief system does to parents
you no longer know this core part of
your child because you are privileged
you're not in that sacred category
so you have the severing of the you know
you have this inverting of the the
relationship with putting the child in
the lead and then you have the severing
of that intuitive knowledge that
instinct because you now can't know this
part of your child
okay and they're sacred okay
um
who can you go to then
to Arbor you be the Arbiter of your
relationship well you have to trust
experts
[Music]
you have to trust experts and you have
to
um ask other trans adults
if you are not trans
and
sorry Rose carry on yeah no so so so I
wanted to share that piece you know it
and then you if you're in that belief
system you then are saying if I am
uncomfortable
I have to stuff it down they actually
have like some of that that doctor in
the Matt Walsh film when I was in the
midst of my anguish and trying to reach
out like where can I find more
information I do Google searches and the
only things I would find
were the people who don't want to
transition their kids are bad
conservatives
and if you're good you are going to do
the gender affirming route so I actually
found a slideshow where that same doctor
um
uh said this is said all the time to
parents you have to grieve you have to
go through a grieving process you have
to grieve the Sun and you have to accept
the daughter
and and so when parents have these
emotions come up there's a bit there's
already the talking points
from both experts and peers to say of
course you're going to have a hard time
with us of course you're going to have a
hard time with us but this is what's
best for your child
and Rose that is a really shocking thing
for me it's the expert the people who
have been trained the people who are
experts the people who should know how
to support children and diagnose them
and put in structures and treatments in
place to help children who are having
some kind of mental suffering whatever
it may be they just seem to have
abandoned their responsibility in
science in favor of an ideology
yeah I mean I think I mean to speak at
least to like the gender therapist that
we saw I mean my perspective is that she
was in therapy because she was an
activist
right you know I think a lot of of
people at this point are um entering
these professions as activists
yeah uh and this is one of the things
that I found incredibly
worrying about what you wrote Because
based on what you're saying it's like
the moment uh you you know your child
says you know you know I'm the opposite
to to the sex that I was born and you go
to all of these different people it
wasn't just therapists it was also the
entire Community right it was people
clapping along the transition
right now keep you know it wasn't
everyone in our community
um but certainly most you know the the
general tone was you know you're doing
the right thing so yes definitely we
went to a couple you know a few
different support groups and and one of
them we were just like told our story
we're like did we do the right thing did
we do the right thing and they're like
you guys are amazing you know you guys
are amazing your child just told you one
day and you changed his entire life
that's that's just incredible
and her entire life surely
ha and and do what did he have initially
positive things at the start did you
initially start to see with the older
child
initially that
he actually had some more positive
moments maybe he became happier did then
did that sort of assuage your fears at
that point
he was never unhappy
but he but he had some he had some
challenges he was different in these
ways but but he certainly was happy
um with this idea of being a girl
um so so yeah so there were some things
that were like that said yes this this
was right you know
um but a lot of them went along with
what people would speak to as sex-based
stereotypes wearing a dress growing his
hair long
um you know being into Elsa you know
um so things that boys can absolutely do
while being boys
um so so yeah there was definitely
enough there and and what we did see is
that it did lock in right so when we
started to question and and and kind of
bring it up to him he didn't want to
talk about it you know he didn't want to
talk about it so
you know part of what like for people
listening you know gender a wider lens
is an amazing podcast and I want to
speak to my story of how I found that a
little bit as well
um but what I will say is that what I
read when I first found that podcast was
that they were in this exploratory
approach like is this a defense is this
some sort of of a defense and I would
say that's similar to what I found over
time with oh my son actually had these
different special interests and that
they changed
um that it wasn't about gender at its
core
um that the locking in of his holding on
to this identity was some sort of
Defense
he I think he needed it to exist as a
boy without a skin like a highly
sensitive boy in this world whose
parents hadn't told him
that he was a boy he but he needed to
know what he was you know and so he when
he locked in there were some defenses
around that and that took us time too
you know to understand that again it
wasn't uh about being innately trans but
rather a defense and he had that
defensive reaction to other things in
his life as well
so that was part of us really putting
the you know whether you call it like
unraveling it or or putting the pieces
together it helped our insight to really
see
um what was going on at a deeper level
and that's what the ideology stops you
from doing
you just say this is this period there's
no understanding of what's underneath
um so I want to speak to the idea like I
think an interesting part of my story is
like how I'm here today talking to you
about this
um because when I uh
when I made that decision where my
partner and I said we're going to hold
our son in this futility that he can't
be a girl you know we came to that from
um
from the process that I'm describing to
you you know really looking at these
different layers of attachment
development maturation what pieces of it
were about being highly sensitive how we
had led him on was a core of that for me
like I've spoken to and taking
responsibility for that
um we came to that decision without
for me without seeing outside the belief
system I still believe that kids could
be innately trans and um
it was just that my kids weren't
um
we made the decision to have that
conversation with him and literally that
night after the kids went to bed I was
up and I did another internet search and
for years I had done internet searches
and I had not found anything that you
know that that was coming from like a
liberal or Progressive kind of aspect
which at that time I needed I'll be
honest with you I don't need that
anymore but at that time I did need that
um and somehow I found this blog fourth
wave now which is out of the United
States
and on that blog they were saying you
know we support lesbian and gay people
but we do not support the medicalization
of children around gender identity and
they were also questioning social
transition
so it's literally that night that I was
like and then they said we're
Progressive you know
um and I just up until that point I
didn't even know people like this
existed
you know and I needed that to bring me
to a point of being like it's okay for
me to question this stuff
and um and that led me to finding the
gender a wider lens podcast and I
listened to the first episode which was
really about really outlining this whole
thing as you know there's generally two
camps there's people who believe in this
thing called gender identity and they
broke down what goes into that belief
and how that looks and they said then
there's people who believe that gender
dysphoria exists and and what goes into
that perspective and how that looks
and it for whatever reason it was like
for the first time
I it helped me see outside of my own
belief I was just in it and you hear D
transitioner speaking to these moments
too where they they're in it they can't
see outside of it until something
happens that like breaks through and um
for whatever reason that did this for me
and so the next morning
I was just sitting in the kitchen I can
visualize the wall in my kitchen um
where I was standing and I'm thinking
about this belief and literally I feel
this is going to sound nuts but I feel
like a pin comes out of my head and the
whole thing just crashes
um and like a second later I'm on my
phone I'm texting a friend I'm like
you know this big thing is happening
um
we've realized that our older son is not
actually transgender and we're going to
be rolling back the social transition
and I feel like I am leaving a cult
because that's what it felt like to me
to just you know we don't have to say
whether it is or isn't like that's just
what I experienced with that
and realizing that I had had a belief
system I didn't know I had a belief
system until that moment and
um and then a second later I hit send
and then I'm
freeze and I think
what if she's like she's in the cult
like she's still in that belief and here
I have just shared this thing and what
you know what is her response gonna be
and so um and and ultimately she
believed us and trusted us and supported
us so that's a that was great but um but
there was this moment for me and and
this is going to be different for
everybody but for me
um you know it's like that was the
feeling that I had
hey Francis do you like locals I live in
London Mike so obviously not the only
pleasure I get from the locals is when
we show an intimate moment as we watch a
Japanese tourists get trapped in a tube
door that is good but I wasn't talking
about their locals I was talking about
our community on locals you mean the one
where you get phenomenal behind the
scenes content when you get you space
when you get to wasp incredible guests
like Jordan Peterson Brett Weinstein
Bill Burr Sam Harris Adam Carolla
Heather Hein and others your questions
not just that you can get supporter only
benefits like trigonometry mugs monthly
calls with our other top supporters and
even a regular meal with me and Francis
you also get phenomenal
behind-the-scenes footage of our trip to
America where we met a whole host of
incredible guests and gave ourselves
terminal indigestion we're also starting
to do monthly giveaways for locals only
the first one will be signed copies of
Andrew door's new book plus you get
access to an incredible community of
like-minded people who share memes have
fun conversations and most importantly
you get to make new friends you can
support us with as little as seven
dollars or about five pounds a month or
give us more for the higher tier
benefits go to
trigonometry.locals.com go to
trigonometry.locals.com and support the
show
what was the reaction from other people
when you you made this decision uh I
can't imagine the gender therapist was
happy oh well we had fired her long
before
two sessions with her and when I came
back from the first one having had that
experience with my younger son
and and we had found some other support
that was coming more from this you know
the attachment-based perspective we had
reached out to some other
people who were more working with
parents rather than children and and um
you know I kind of you know I
she threatened me in the second one so
this was big
to laugh at this so
um when I was like no he said he didn't
want to you know no I'm not gonna do
this she was like well if you don't he's
going to develop an attachment disorder
and and I was like um you don't know
anything about attachment
like that's clear I know so much more
than you do and if my son is gonna have
these issues I know how to see them you
know there was just it was just such
utter [__] at that point that I that
I you know could walk away pretty easily
and so I would say for parents who are
very enmeshed with the experts and in
peer groups this is going to be hard you
know we were so fortunate we I had the
strength and we had the confidence in us
that we had we had left the experts long
before and we had never gone full in
with them and so um that helped a lot
but I would say
you know what we had in terms of like
taking that off-ramp what I what I told
some people in my life like my some of
my brothers I said
it's much easier to get on than off
and um so getting off was hard and
um and uh we had some conversations with
different individuals in our lives that
um were difficult and we had to really
pick and choose
who we could trust with the full
information of how we came to this
decision and what we did with it and who
we had to really
um give just the basics
and um and we had to kind of navigate
through that and we did have one person
in our life
um a couple different people who were
like you know trying to get us to go to
counselors um we had uh uh and we're
like no we're clear we're good you know
um
and we did have um
you know
a a kind of a teacher of our children's
past who we had shared some of this with
and who really you know was is deeply in
that belief system enough that she you
know was like I I can't believe you're
not letting your kids choose their
pronouns you know
um really unsettled by that aspect of it
and so
we just had to navigate it there was
nothing else to do and and I think that
anchoring for me in
I led my child into this it was my
responsibility to take him off was just
what held me solid through through all
of that and that's what those instincts
that I had shut down
and those feelings and those emotions
because what I I had experiencing that
thing I taught you about that severing
of that relationship that inversion I
felt that just
um
physically I felt that emotionally and
so when it came back in to to place for
me that's when I realized how much it
had been severed and so nothing was
going to stop me from defending it at
that point
and Rose what are your how are your sons
now
um I think they're both
um yeah yeah it you know it's there was
a time period where it was much harder I
will say for my younger son as soon as
his older brother was his older brother
he was like great
you know I'm good
he had more distress he was very
distressed and I want to tell this story
really quickly
um we did never social transitioned our
younger son like I spoke to but he
showed so much to stress over it
you know it was so ironic that our older
son had no distress we transitioned him
our younger son had a ton of distress
and we had to at that point hold our
ground and not do it because we
understood what was underneath and um
but there was I'm sorry to interrupt
what was the distress
caused by
um by this drive to be the same as his
older sibling
yeah
conflicting with the fact that he also
knew that he was a boy no the fact that
we wouldn't let him use she her pronouns
so after that moment in the BET and you
know in the you know hey you're my girl
and you know I love you and he said
don't call me that right he continued to
want to be she her
in right always keep in mind this was
always and practically only in the
context of when they would go out and
his older brother was she her in like a
camp setting or a you know the
after-school program whatever it was
um that's when it was most distressing
to him he was away from us and he needed
to be close to his brother
and he needed that closeness through
being the same and we weren't letting
him do it
and um so just as an example of that
um they went to Camp he was four his
older brother was six and um
his older brother was with the girls he
was with the boys he came home so upset
just so distraught and he and I kept on
going back to you know we're not
changing this you know
he looked at me he's four years old
and he said Mama
when I hear he it means [__]
and this is another thing we could do a
whole nother like five podcasts on what
we are doing to these little boys
Rose
there were a lot of people unfortunately
who are in a very similar situation to
you all around the world
they might well be listening to this and
I hope they are watching it what advice
would you give to those parents who are
going through a similar situation to you
um the biggest piece of advice that I
would give is that it is not transphobic
to question
it is not uh transphobic to question
whether or not
essentially telling your child that they
can change sex
is in their best interest
it's not transphobic to
not feel good
about this what you know what you're
doing or what you're being told to do to
feel uncomfortable with it and it's
a place where I just really encourage
people if you have doubts to listen to
them
and what was important to me to hold my
ground through this whole thing and what
we had to navigate with other people who
wanted us to keep our child in that
sacred status people some people did not
want to hear that it wasn't working
um and that we're that it was going to
change
um you have to
picture
your child at 20 years old 30 years old
40 year old 50 year old
what is their life going to look like
then and those experts those friends
those neighbors whoever they are who are
like you know telling you what to do are
not going to be there for your child
you are
um and I think some people have I've
talked about this seeing it as a highway
some people have talked about this as a
train
you know if you are affirming your child
currently you have put your child on
that train your child is on a train and
it has one destination
okay
and
um what you you know I just say I did it
you can do it
you need to have the courage to grab
your child's hand and jump off
and there may be distress there may be
anger there may be tears at the impact
but just be patient stay calm and over
time healing healing will come
and Rose what are your thoughts on as a
consequence of your experiences on the
idea and the ideology itself like the
obviously I think you've probably
shifted somewhat in your opinions but
um how you know how far did you go the
other way I guess is what I'm asking do
you think no one's trans do you think
some people are like what is your what
are your overall thoughts on that whole
thing
I would say you know I am it's an
ongoing process of reflection for me I I
absolutely I have people who are
identifies Trans in my life you know and
who I love
um who are adults and um
I think I think just like I'm speaking
to for my own process that that that
there's going to be a complex set of
factors that go into that identification
for adults
um I I no longer believe that that this
is something that is innate that is born
in people
um and so that whole piece you know was
important for me to come to but I do
believe that that for many people this
identification feels like a core part of
themselves
and um I I do think that
a lot of that is likely coming from this
belief system you know and it's not that
um I I you know that they're you know
there are adults in my life who feel
good with having taken on gone the
medical route or who feel good about
being in the non-binary you know space
um but I what I no longer believe is
that this is something that should be
evangelized and and institutional and
pushed on children uh this concept of
gender identity I I no longer believe in
that
um
as something and I do find it to be
quite dangerous and and in so many ways
and does it does it worry you that
particularly in the States this is being
used more and more in schools
particularly in primary schools for sure
yes yes absolutely
um yeah I have two you know another
story here you know my my younger son is
in second grade and in their small
school
um they have two non-binary staff
assistants and one of them is in my my
son's second grade class and um
and his teacher again best intentions
she wants to make sure that this adult
is included and respected by the
children and
um because of that she started off the
school year saying if you change your
name the rule for this class is that you
have to respect
the new name and so some kids the first
day change their names
it wasn't a long gender it was just kind
of random but um but there is this yes I
am I'll say I am deeply concerned
um that the children are being told that
it's a matter of respect
uh to do these things
I think the the core Point as well out
of everything you've said today is the
fundamental idea that children should
lead is the most insane thing that
anyone has ever come up with in relation
to Parenting is it not I mean they're
literally I I you know I had a my son is
eight months old and
you know I I think I see him growing
he's getting smarter he's not going to
know what gender or sex is or what
identity is it three years old he's not
qualified to make that decision
it's just it's I had no idea about his
lift experience yeah well I don't but
we'll find out what is his lived
experience is mainly pooing in his pants
and and drinking milk that's all he does
right my point is
you know the very notion that children
should lead yeah is insane
it's insane and how we've got to this
place that so many people believe it uh
it is terrifying which is why I'm so
grateful uh for your time Rose I'm so
grateful you wrote the piece that you
wrote and you came on the show to talk
about it because I say again I think
your voice is very necessary people need
to hear this
um people need to understand that there
are consequences to ideology and their
consequences to idealism of the types
that you thank God your your kids in the
long run avoid it I'm so pleased to hear
that they're they're doing well now yeah
and can I Circle back just really
quickly to the question you asked me
Francis around what do I believe now I
feel like I'm kind of like what I got a
little lost there I wanted to say
Michael my core belief at this point
when you say how I change it just really
rests on the fact that it is impossible
to change sex
that if if I could just sum up you know
what do I believe about this now it is
impossible to change sex
based on that should why are we telling
children that they can
yeah that's what it's like to sum it up
thank you so much for coming on the show
we're going to do a couple of questions
from our local supporters that only they
will get to see but before we wrap up as
always we have one final question for
you which is what's the one thing we're
not talking about as a society that you
think we really should be uh this is I
was thinking about this ahead of time
I'm like I don't know how to answer that
um
but what I really came to I guess
you know and maybe this is more for like
let's just put it out there to the
parents putting it out there to the
parents so
um there is so much when you are aware
of these issues like gender ideology in
the schools capture of Institutions all
of these things
you know they and and maybe parents out
there whose children are in this deep
um and uh it is so scary it's just so
deeply alarming
um
and I think what I keep I worry for my
son's future you know and I worry for
their kids and
what I keep on coming back to is the
this core concept of attachment and so
number one we should be talking more
about attachment people should all go
out and read hold on to your kids Dr
Gordon neufeld's book
um but what what what we really need to
come back to is understanding that the
power that we have we can't Maybe
change the whole dynamic of the big
picture
um but as parents what we do have the
power over is how we can show love and
delight and warmth towards our children
and that that cultivation of that
relationship
um is what is going to be their greatest
shield in navigating society and these
different perils that they're going to
have to go through
um so the question that I have that I
want to put out there to everybody is
when is the last time that your child
entered the room and you showed Delight
at their presence
it's a really really powerful note to
end on and something for all of us to
think about Rose it's been an absolute
Joy if people want to find you on sub
stack where what is the best way to do
that
um so uh you can go to the parents with
inconvenient truths around trans sub
stack I
um hope to have my own substance someday
I don't yet but um also please support
and find out more about uh genspect
genspect is an amazing organization
um that supports the pit the parents
with inconvenient truths around trans
substack and efforts they're doing work
at the international level to just
really ground us
um in a reality and exploration around
these issues of gender
uh Rose thank you so much for coming on
the show we'll go to our locals in a
second but for now thank you for being
here and thank you guys for watching and
listening we will see you very soon with
another brilliant episode like this one
or raw show all of them come out at 7pm
UK time and for those of you who like
your trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
is there anything that a healthcare
professional could have said to you that
would have stopped you trying to
socially transition your child
foreign
[Music]